welcome Madam president Mr President uh
it's great to see you both again and uh
last Summit we committed to revitalizing
the partnership between the EU and the
United States and uh over the last two
years we made good in that commitment I
think and uh we stood together to
support the brave people of Ukraine in
the face of Putin's aggression and we
stood together to tackle the economic
challenges and establish standards to
guide our relationship with China and uh
standing together now to support Israel
in his wake of aasa's appalling
terrorist attack and uh I I just think
that uh it's it's been one of the great
pleasures of my presidency to be able to
work with part I mean that sincerely
this morning we're going to discuss the
situation on both ground of both Israel
and Ukraine and I look forward to
discussing how we're going to continue
to seize the full potential of our
partnership including working together
to drive the clean energy transition to
address unfairly traded steel aluminum
Imports to advance progress on critical
mineral negotiations that's under
undergoing and uh and to manage a
problem that also has a lot of Promise
as much as gr artificial intelligence
and uh so I want to thank you both for
being here and for your unwavering
commitment to our partnership and um
president Michelle will turn it over to
you thank you dear president um thank
you for your warm welcome the EU and us
we share a special bond we are more than
close allies we are close friends and I
remember when you visited Brussels you
told us the moving story of your uncle
friend who served at the Battle of the
belch in Belgium I have also a personal
story my grandfather raised me with a
strong admiration for your country for
United States and for the sacrifices
your young men and women made to
liberate our part of Belgium today the
world faces enormous challenges and
today more than ever the world needs a
strong EU us Alliance to tackle these
challenges the conflict in the Middle
East is a tragedy so much suffering so
many heartbreaking images I would like
to thank you for your personal
involvement traveling to the region and
working to have a positive influence we
condemn the Hamas and its terrorist
attack against Israel Israel has the
right to defend itself and that must be
done in line with International and
humanitarian law we continue working day
and night to help the most vulnerable in
Palestine with their urgent needs and to
Foster the conditions to relaunch the
peace process based on the two- State
solution the EU was born as a peace
project so we continue to work tily to
help end the cycle of violence on
European so Russia continue to rain
missiles down on the people of Ukraine
and we stay focused on our strong
support for the Ukrainian people and we
are grateful for America's support for
Ukraine the EU with our member states we
have provided over 82 billion EUR of
support and the strong backing will
continue for as States finally the U the
EU and us we are forging a united front
to tackle all these challenges head on
working together together and supporting
each other is our in our mutual interest
and it is good for the world that's why
we are working in the EU to try to build
robust economies underpinned by robust
industries that can prosper in a Level
Playing Field that we both value the EU
and us we have a powerful trade
relationship and sometimes we have our
differences but that's why we are here
to cooperate to find solutions that work
for businesses and workers on both Sid
SI of the Atlantic so we have a lot to
discuss we'll do it honestly like good
friends do thank you we always have and
by the way I told you about my uncle who
won the Purple Heart Battle of balls and
my father's younger brother my father
came to me after I was a Senator and he
said you know his brother's name was
Frank and he said you know Uncle Frank
uh never got his purple heart I think
you could find out about that I was a
senator so I found out and sure enough
he did so I got a purple heart for him
to invited him over to the house of the
family to give it to him he said I don't
want the damn
thing I said why he said the others died
I did I don't want
to and uh an awful lot of brave people
died as well there Ursa
M the floor is yours thank you very much
speaking of personal transatlantic bonds
my great
grandmother came from South Carolina and
she moved the other way around to
Germany married
my married my
great-grandfather and to make a longer
story short today I am the proud mother
of two American citizens and as those
citizens American citizens have already
children again I'm also the proud
grandmother of one American citizen so
we have a lot of personal Bond better
transatlantic Mr President um I want to
thank you for your remarkable visit to
Israel it is important to show
solidarity with Israel victim of the
worst attack since the Sha Israel has
the right for to self-defense in line
with humanitarian law I was in Israel
too exactly one week ago I went to the
kibuts AA what I saw was
barbaric the impact on the Israeli
Society cannot be emphasized enough we
stand with Israel and against Terror at
the same time Palestinians also suffer
from Hamas terroristic actions as we
have both said Hamas does not represent
the Palestinian people the United States
and the European Union are both
significantly increasing their
humanitarian Aid to civilians in Gaza
this is crucial in view of their
suffering and we must also work actively
to prevent Regional
escalation I'm particularly concerned
about Iran and its
proxies we have all seen the incidents
in evolving missiles and drones from
Yemen potentially targeting
Israel no one should take advantage of
this
situation and let me also stress the
events in the Middle East will not
distract us from our Rock Solid support
to
Ukraine we have already provided
assistance worth almost 90 billion to
Ukraine this includes financial support
to keep the state and the economy
running military equipment humanitarian
Aid and support for 4 million
refugees in the next 4 years we aim to
provide another 50 billion EUR important
is for Ukraine to have
predictability we are also making sure
through our joint actions that Russia's
ability to wage war is hampered as much
as possible and that those responsible
are held
accountable Putin will ultimately fail
he is running Russia into the
ground these conflicts show democracies
must stand
together this is also true when it comes
to other big Challen es like fighting
climate change fostering smart
investment in emerging economies or
upholding our rules based International
order so I'm very happy to be here today
to discuss all these topics with our
friends the United States I'm happy to
have all of you thanks